what is the most annoying thing about
being married tell me what's the most
annoying thing about being married
what's the most annoying thing about
being a girl you can say my wife is
watching this yeah
what's the most annoying thing about
being married what's the most annoying
my response is not going to be as mature
as your response well then give it to me
go ahead she wouldn't let me go out and
party with like okay it's like
married well by the way by the way that
is one of the annoying just let me go do
my thing yeah let me get the entire
video yeah i gotta tell you you know
i've never been married but my ex was
about as close as god like you don't
marry her you marry the whole family
that's true so awful by the way an
absolute very good point because when
you do marriage your sister was the
worst human being i don't even know her
look at that camera right now talk to
that story right now
what is the most annoying thing she's
like she's like a human it's like they
took ashtrays they took the ashes from a
cigarette train somehow animated into a
human being this is soulless decrepit
human being your sister is what oh my
god what if you're not still hung up on
it that's good yeah
what so when you think about single guys
that want to get married what's the
what's the biggest thing that happens a
week before guy's going to get married
what do you hear about go to your
bachelor parties no no but what did you
hear about guys having anxiety attacks
guys having like panic attacks going to
their bodies how would you do it i don't
know if is this it i don't know if i'm
ready
you know like the whole runaway bride
there's a lot of runaway grooms you know
runaway you know
i don't want to out you guys here i mean
but you know like
the one woman for the rest of your life
is a tough that's a that's a
betting you're in betting half of your
salary
against
betting half of your entire wealth
against the gerard just went vegas okay
so it's all odds that's what we're doing
against your hormones hang on guys david
the voice of god has got something to
say tell us david what's the reason
that's what single guys say what gerard
just said and what's up
it's what single guys say yeah i'm
giving her half of your wealth it's
about spending the rest of your life
with the person you live
with that voice david
now but you know what it is here's what
it is okay here's what it is just think
about it number one it's the r word what
is the r word maybe one of the most
responsibilities it sucks it's annoying
right i don't want it it's the a word
what's the award
accountability sucks
it's the c word what's the c word
commitment
commitment sucks
okay so those three things is there a d
word yeah you know yeah but
she didn't hear it from me exactly is
that there an f word that only happens
once a month what is the deal but the
point is the point the point is you got
those three things responsibility
accountability commitment those three
things are annoying anything big you
ever do in your life requires all those
three things yeah and it sucks it
doesn't matter what you're doing you
want to be in shape you want to work out
you want to win a championship you want
to get your super bowl ring you want to
be a millionaire you want to be a
billionaire you want to make it on the
list you want to build a big church you
want to be
you know 80 human trafficking raising a
billion dollars the next 20 years and
doing what you're doing any of that
stuff requires record you have to be
responsible to your diet if you want to
be in shape you have to be accountable
to a train you have to be committed to
show up at six o'clock it absolutely
sucks but on the other end of it
holy freaking molly on the other end of
it is
that that visual of
your at a school kid is graduating you
see your son
your daughter and you have that moment
together on all the things you overcame
those things are priceless that's what
makes relationships unique that's what
makes marriage unique that's what makes
friendships relationships there's
something about it so those three most
annoying words in the world
responsibility accountability and
commitment i will say all of the most
successful men i know in life in
business in sports
all dutifully married dutifully married
well here's my question
would you get married if there were no
kids involved would you just be a
married couple no kids
so so i'll hypothetical question listen
i listen we were talking about this the
other night at the house right we were
up till god knows what time that night
we were strategizing phenomenal session
that day we had we had nice cigars we
had nice drinks we had everything except
we didn't have cutters and lighters
which is i don't know how you get cigars
without cutters and lighters but it is
what it is one of the podcasts i was
listening to weirdest podcast i listened
to but it was absolutely i couldn't stop
listening to it okay
the podcast had four people there one
guy who's single who doesn't believe in
god doesn't go to church atheist who
thinks you need to be promiscuous and
he's left and right going out there and
hooking up he says that's what you need
to do swipe right every day why not get
it out of your system
the second one is a a newlywed a
newlywed who doesn't want to have kids
and all they want to do is the rest of
their lives they just want to be
together they don't want to have kids
right it makes no sense another one is
in their 40s they have kids kids are you
know high school about to go to college
and they're going through the struggles
and another couple that was there was a
christian pastor
that was married they're in their 60s
and they're going through all this stuff
so the young guy's talking about sex all
this stuff the middle husband and wife
are talking about we got to get our
connection to be better in this area and
that area everybody's telling their
issues right and then a 60-something
year old says like when i was younger i
didn't think i thought marriage was just
about kids i thought marriage was just
about this he says wait till you're
married
and then your wife has to have a surgery
that you can't have have sex for six
months your marriage will be tested and
that's what happened to us
and i had the biggest fights with my
wife and this and this and that and it
was the worst thing but you know what
happened two years later two years later
i couldn't get it up
he's saying this on the podcast
he says now try facing your wife and
every time you're in the bedroom you're
like oh you know it's i you know you
know i drank too much or you know i'm
sorry it was a bad day you know i didn't
have enough pineapple right whatever
excuses you're going to make you're like
oh you know you try to change the
subject you want to go to dinner you
want to go it's awkward and he's telling
the story
and he says but as you get older you're
going to realize companionship is very
important once kids are gone everybody
is gone the last thing you're gonna fear
is in your 60s 70s is being by yourself
in a house
and if you can get a 28 year old come to
your house you can get a 32 year old
come to your house but what is the depth
of that relationship yesterday we talked
about how do you how do you
measure a successful marriage and
business
how do you measure successful marriage
and business what is it is it
how many employees you got is it how
much money you make and the way you
measure a successful business or
marriage is what depth and duration
how many guys know people that have been
married for 50 years and are miserable i
know a lot of people we talk about one
of people you know that are married and
not happily happy together right then
the other one is depth
you see depth you see a business we've
been around for 100 years but we want to
make 100 grand a year well we've been
around for 100 years but we have 17 000
employees and we have a legacy of this
this this that right so to me there's a
little bit of both yeah this is like the
matt zapala thing
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]